>> Laura: PICKING UP WHERE WE
LEFT OFF IN LAST NIGHTS ANGLE,
WE ARE LOOKING INTO THE ROLE
FORMER OBAMA OFFICIALS PLAYED IN
SETTING AN INTEL TRAP AGAINST
THE TRUMP CHAIN.
BUT THE DAM OF EVIDENCE NOW
BURSTING, FORMER OBAMA OFFICIALS
ARE TRYING TO MUDDY THE WATERS
BUT DOING SO IN CONFUSION.
>> IS THERE ANYTHING IN THE
DOSSIER THAT HAS BEEN DISPROVEN?
>> NO, SOME OF IT HASN'T BEEN
PROVEN AND SOME OF IT HASN'T
BEEN -- NO.
I GUESS THE SHORT ANSWER TO THE
QUESTION, THERE IS NO
COOPERATION OF THAT
KNOWLEDGE.
>> Laura: NOTHING HAS BEEN
DISPROVED?
HOW WOULD HE KNOW?
HE HASN'T BEEN THE DIRECTOR FOR
A YEAR AND A HALF.
AND THAT'S OPPOSITE OF THE
TREES.
NONE OF THE WILD CLAIMS IN THE
DOSSIER HAVE BEEN PROVEN, NOT
PUBLICLY.
YOU CAN BET IF ANYONE WERE TRUE,
THAT WOULD BE FOUND BY NOW.
FLAPPERS STATEMENT ISN'T EVEN
ACCURATE, THE DOSSIER
INCORRECTLY CLAIMED THAT
MICHAEL: WENT TO PRAGUE TO MEET
WITH THE RUSSIANS.
OF COURSE HE'S NEVER BEEN TO
PRAGUE, NO PUBLIC EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
BUT WHAT'S REALLY TELLING ABOUT
CLAPPER'S REMARK IS THAT HE
GIVES AWAY THE DEEP STATE
STRATEGY.
WHAT IS IT?
IT'S BASICALLY CREATE SO MUCH
DOUBT AND CONFUSION THAT
AMERICANS GIVE UP TRYING TO MAKE
SENSE OF ANY OF IT.
TO THAT END, CLAPPER AND FELLOW
OBAMA ALUMS ARE PUSHING THE LINE
THAT, IF A DOSSIER CAN'T BE
DISPROVED, IT MUST BE TRUE.
WELL LET'S DISCUSS HOW WELL THAT
STRATEGY WILL WORK IN LIGHT OF
ALL THE RECENT DEVELOPMENTS WITH
FORMER CIA ANALYST JOHN KERRY
ARCO, REPUBLICAN CONGRESSMAN
STEVE RUSSELL, AND ASSISTANT
ATTORNEY GENERAL ROBERT DISTRICT
ON MIKE DRISCOLL.
CONGRESSMAN, THIS IS WILD.
I MEAN THE NEVER ENDING MEDIA
APPEARANCES BY JIM KLAPPER.
WE WERE JOKING EARLIER, HE MUST
BE PROMOTING A BOOK.
AND HE IS INDEED.
WHAT'S YOUR TAKE ON WHAT HE SAID
RIGHT THERE?
>> IT JUST SHOWS THAT THIS IS
REALLY A HOUSE OF CARDS.
YOU THINK THEY ARE TRYING TO
MAKE SOMETHING THAT THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE OF AND WHEN THEY TALK
ABOUT PEOPLE BEING GUILTY AND
ADDS NO EVIDENCE OF COLLUSION.
THEY SEE RIGHT THROUGH THIS AND
IT'S A CONTINUAL STRAW MAN
ARGUMENT AND THEY CONTINUE TO
PUSH IT EVERY WAY THEY CAN.
>> Laura: THAT MEETING AT THE
WHITE HOUSE TODAY, IT'S NOT
CLEAR WHAT DOCUMENTS WERE
ACTUALLY PRESENTED TO DEVIN
NUNES OR TO TREY GADDY.
WERE THEY ABLE TO LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENTS WERE NOT LOOK AT THE
DOCUMENTS?
THE DETAILS OF THE MEETING WILL
NOT BE RELEASED.
>> THEY WERE TIGHT-LIPPED ABOUT
THIS.
>> AS THEY SHOULD BE.
BUT I THINK THE BIGGER CONCERN
IS, WILL DEVON NUNEZ AND TREY
GOWDY BE ABLE TO GET THE
INFORMATION, LOOK AT THE
INFORMATION WITHOUT REDUCTION?
WE SEE THESE PROBLEMS WHERE THEY
WILL REDACT THINGS, WITHHOLDING
IT FROM CONGRESS.
WELL, SINCE 1840 IN THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE, WE HAVE
THAT RESPONSIBILITY.
NOTHING SHOULD BE REDACTED FROM
CONGRESS, THEY NEED TO GET TO
THE FACTS.
>> Laura: THIS IS WHAT ADAM
SCHIFF SAID ABOUT THE MEETING,
LET'S WATCH.
>> NOTHING WE HEARD TODAY HAS
CHANGED OUR VIEW, THAT THERE IS
NO EVIDENCE TO SUPPORT ANY
ALLEGATION THAT THE FBI OR ANY
INTELLIGENCE AGENCY PLACED A SPY
IN THE KEY TRUMP CAMPAIGN OR
OTHERWISE FAILED TO FOLLOW
APPROPRIATE PROCEDURES AND
PROTOCOLS.
>> Laura: APPARENTLY THEY
ACTUALLY DIDN'T HAVE THE ACCESS
TO THE DOCUMENTS THAT THEY
WANTED, AT LEAST IT'S NOT CLEAR
THAT THEY DID.
APPARENTLY THEY DIDN'T SEE ALL
THE DOCUMENTS, AGAIN.
>> AND WHAT I TOOK FROM WHAT HE
SAID, IT'S VERY CAREFULLY WORDED
STATEMENT.
THERE IS NO EVIDENCE THAT THEY
PLACED A SPY IN THE CAMPAIGN.
I COULD STILL MEAN YOU HAD A
CONFIDENTIAL INFORMANT CONTACT
PEOPLE ON THE CAMPAIGN AND
RECORD THEIR CONVERSATION, IT
MEANS THEY DIDN'T HAVE AN IN BED
IN THE CAMPAIGN.
I GET THAT, BUT IT'S NOT
NECESSARILY WHAT IS OF MOST
CONCERN TO CONGRESS.
I THINK WHAT IS INTERESTING TO
ME IS THAT TRUMP COULD
DECLASSIFY ALL THIS STUFF
HIMSELF WITH THE STROKE OF A
PEN.
HE'S ACTUALLY SHOWING SOME
DEFERENCE TO THE DOJ.
HE'S ALMOST PLAYING A MEDIATING
ROLE RATHER THAN ACTING AS THE
HEAD OF THE EXECUTIVE BRANCH
SAME, CONGRESS HAS A POINT,
THERE NEEDS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENCY HERE.
I'M NOT GOING TO FORCE YOU TO
DISCLOSE EVERYTHING.
>> Laura: HONEST REASONS FOR
REDUCTION.
>> BUT I COULDN'T GET OVER THE
$70,000 CONFERENCE ROOM TABLE
THAT SENATOR MCCAIN BROUGHT.
>> THEN THEY GET ON BEN CARSON'S
WIFE FOR THE TABLE.
HOW MUCH WAS THAT?
11,000?
WHERE DO THEY GET THEIR TABLES?
THEY MUST GO TO THE STOREHOUSE
OR WHATEVER.
COME ON.
WE'VE BEEN TALKING A LOT ABOUT
THE OVERREACH OF THE
SURVEILLANCE STATE.
I DID A BIG PIECE ON THIS LAST
NIGHT.
SINCE 9/11, I GUESS ALL THESE
GOOD INTENTIONS -- WE WANT TO
KEEP THE NATION SAFE, BUT WE
HAVE CREATED A SURVEILLANCE
SUPERSTATE IN THIS COUNTRY.
AND I THINK ALL THESE PEOPLE AT
THE TOP THINK THEY ARE BEYOND
REPROACH AND THEY ARE SO
CONFIDENT THAT THEY ARE RIGHT,
THEY WANT TO DO WHAT THEY WANT
TO DO WITH IMPUNITY.
AND THAT'S THE DEEP STATE.
>> I'M GLAD YOU CALL IT THE DEEP
STATE BECAUSE IT EXISTS.
IT'S THERE, AND IT'S POWER
FOREVER.
AND THOSE PATRIOTS AT THE CIA
AND ELSEWHERE, MANY OF THEM CAME
OF AGE AND ENTERED INTO THE
SENIOR INTELLIGENCE SERVICE
DURING THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION.
FOR MANY OF THEM THAT'S WHERE
THEIR LOYALTIES LIE.
SO THERE REALLY IS A DEEP STATE.
THE CONGRESSMAN MANDATE A VERY
IMPORTANT POINT ALSO AND THAT'S
ABOUT CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT.
THE CIA AS PART OF ITS VERY
NATURE PUSHES BACK ON
CONGRESSIONAL OVERSIGHT, AND
THEY HAVE TO FIGHT FOR ITS
RIGHTFUL OVERSIGHT.
>> AND HE LEAKED THE INFORMATION
ABOUT WATERBOARDING, LONG STORY,
MOST OF THE CHARGES WERE DROPPED
AND ONE REMAINS.
BUT YOU FELT WHAT HAPPENED WHEN
YOU DECIDED TO SAY, IT DIDN'T
SEEM RIGHT TO YOU.
LIKE I DON'T LOSE SLEEP ABOUT
WATERBOARDING, I KNOW A LOT OF
PEOPLE DO.
BUT YOU FEEL THAT THE WAY THINGS
HAVE DEVELOPED IN THIS COUNTRY
WITH THE EXPLOSION OF THE INTEL
AGENCIES THAT IT'S VERY HARD FOR
CONGRESSMAN RUSSELL AND DEVIN
NUNES, TREY GOWDY AND FRANKLY
THE DEMOCRATS IF THEY WERE ON TO
ACTUALLY SEE, WHAT'S GOING ON
HERE.
YOU HAVE THESE SITES, AND YOU
WONDER, WHAT'S HAPPENING HERE.
IT HAS A NATURAL TENSION, BUT
IT'S WORSE THE BIGGER THE INTEL
STATE IS, THE SUPERSTATE, THE
HARDER IT IS.
>> CORRECT.
AND REMEMBER I GOT FAR WORSE.
JOHN BRENNAN HAD WHAT FORMER
COLLEAGUES OF MINE HAVE SAID IS
A NIXONIAN OBSESSION.
THAT'S NEARLY THREE TIMES AS ALL
PREVIOUS PRESIDENTS COMBINED AND
IT WASN'T REALLY ABOUT THOSE
INDIVIDUALS.
IT WAS ABOUT SENDING A MESSAGE
TO THE REST OF THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE TO KEEP YOUR MOUTH
SHUT.
>> Laura: DON'T YOU DARE.
THAT'S A LITTLE MAFIA ASKED.
CONGRESSMAN, I WANT YOU BOTH TO
RESPOND.
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS IS GOING.
THE LEFT IS TRYING TO FIND THE
I DON'T THINK INFORMANTS IN THE
CAMPAIGN ARE TRYING TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH THE CAMPAIGN AS A
SIDE ISSUE.
I THINK IT'S A SIDE ISSUE WHEN
THEY SAY, THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER
AND CHIEF OF STAFF WERE AT A
MEETING FOR A SHORT PERIOD OF
TIME.
THEY WERE FREAKING OUT ABOUT
THIS TODAY, LET'S WATCH.
>> I WAS STUNNED WHEN I HEARD
EMMET FLOOD ATTENDED, EVEN IF HE
WASN'T THERE FOR THE CLASSIFIED
PART OF IT, THAT HE WOULD EVEN
SHOW HIS PRESENCE.
>> THE PRESENCE OF EMMET FLOOD
EVEN IF IT WAS JUST TO MAKE
INTRODUCTORY REMARKS CLEARLY NOW
>> WHAT WE SAW TODAY WAS
IMPROPER, AND IT DID RISK
UNDERMINING PARTS OF THE MUELLER
PROGRAM.
>> Laura: I DON'T KNOW IF
THESE PEOPLE KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT
THE LAW.
THEY WERE THERE TO SAY, WE WANT
TO HELP, WE WANT TRANSPARENCY.
AND THEY STAYED APPARENTLY FOR A
SHORTER PERIOD OF TIME, AND THEN
THEY WERE GONE.
>> IT'S THE TYPICAL PLAYBOOK.
PUT UP SOME SHINY OBJECT AND
DISTRACT FROM THE FACT.
>> ROBERT.
>> AGAIN, IT'S KIND OF
COMMONPLACE.
THE PRESIDENT AGAIN IS PLAYING A
MEDIATING ROLE IN THIS AND I
THINK ALL THAT HAPPENED WAS A
FLOOD WAS THERE AT THE
BEGINNING, HE SAID THE PRESIDENT
WANTS YOU GUYS TO RELEASE AS
MUCH AS YOU CAN, AND THEN THEY
WALKED OUT PRIOR TO THE
CLASSIFIED PORTION OF THE
BRIEFINGS.
>> Laura:
MEETING, LIKE CALLING ON YOU AND
YOU.
THAT'S HOW IT WENT DOWN.
>> YOU HAVE TO PICK A BRANCH,
AND THE DOJ WORK FOR THE
PRESIDENT SO IT'S NOT
INAPPROPRIATE FOR THE
PRESIDENT AND WHITE HOUSE
COUNSEL TO SAY PRIOR TO THE
MEETING, WE WORK FOR US, HERE'S
WHERE THE BOSS WANTS TO GO FOR
THIS.
HE WANTS MAXIMUM TRANSPARENCY.
>> Laura: I HAVE TO ASK YOU,
WHAT IS THE LIKELIHOOD THAT ONLY
ONE INFORMANT.
THIS HAPLESS HELPER, APPARENTLY,
THIS PROFESSOR, IS THE ONLY
PERSON WHO WAS TASKED WITH SOME
TYPE OF OUTREACH TO THE TRUMP
CAMPAIGN.
DOESN'T THAT SEEM ODD THAT IT
WOULD BE JUST ONE GUY?
IF THEY REALLY WANT TO GET
ANSWERS, JUST ONE GUY?
>> THE AUSTRALIAN CONTACT WAS
THE ONE THAT WAS ALWAYS A
QUESTION TO ME.
I'VE BEEN IN A LOT OF BARS WITH
A LOT OF PEOPLE WHO HAVE SAID
STUPID STUFF, AND THE NOTION
THAT I WOULD RUN TO THE FBI OR
RUN TO AN INTELLIGENCE AGENCY
BASED ON A LATE NIGHT
CONVERSATION, AND IT SEEMS KIND
OF STRANGE TO ME.
AND IT'S COMMON BEHAVIOR,
>> Laura: WE ARE ALMOST OUT OF
TIME, BUT I WILL BRING MORE
PEOPLE BACK.
I WOULD BRING A LEG AT TERRA
POLSKA, AND I WOULD GET ALL
THESE PEOPLE BACK.
THEY ARE NOT GETTING THE ANSWERS
WE DESERVE.
AND BRINGING PEOPLE BACK TO